okay things are sort of mixed up this
week because of the 4th of July holiday
so the Wednesday show is going to be the
day we take live calls instead of the
Friday show that would cause us to miss
out on hatred mail which a lot of people
don't want to do so we were going to get
to hatred mail a day early today quick
reminder what is hatred mail this is
hatred mail hey we'd probably poison our
entire family if trump told us to but
remember it's not a cult patriot mail
written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom okay
this week's hatred mail picking up on a
theme from Donald Trump's State of the
Union address and that has continued
which is the theme of this is not going
to become a communist country which of
course is a total straw man talking
point because there's really no threat
of the United States becoming a
communist country take a listen to this
Pakman is a wishy-washy wordsmithing jew
using vague terms like progressives when
it's all if cover for social democracy
socialism communism and our kisum etc
progressive doesn't mean [ __ ] just
because a vague idea of progress is
involved it communists specific kind as
progress they see it as conservativism
in human clothes we will never be
communists mag saw ya mags uh some kind
of make America great Lee stupid again I
guess is what Magda would mean I'm gonna
assume that's a typo based on the
proximity of a and s on computer
keyboards the number one way to fight
hate reott ISM and to push back against
it is to sign up for a David Pakman show
membership and use the coupon code hey
tree at forty the coupon code hey tree
at forty saves you forty percent off of
a membership you get all of the same
member benefits as everybody else who
paid full price and hey tree 'it's don't
like it when their hate reott ism leads
to membership hey tree at forty is the
coupon code it'll save you forty percent
off of the member
ship of your choice at WWN pakman.com